this video is brought to you by
expressvpn and Shopify people more on
them after the
reaction what is going on there citizens
of the reject Nation Greg here today so
I am going to do a first time watching
for a movie that I am very much looking
forward to I've heard a lot of good
things about and I am the one at the
channel who hasn't seen it so it's a
solo one today and that is for the movie
The Impossible I know it's about a
tsunami I know it stars a young Tom
Holland I'm very much looking forward to
it but guys what do you think about
about this movie leave your thoughts in
the comments down below did it affect
you I hear this is a strong film
whatever that means powerful dramatic
moving tell me what you think about it
what's an impossible thing you've had to
overcome that's a more YouTuber question
anyway guys listen go ahead leave a like
on this video that'd be very much
appreciated be sure to subscribe click
that notification Bell to get notified
when we get a reaction up on this
channel that Peaks our interest because
we got a lot in the can that we have
already shot also big thank you to
prepper for helping us head it down
these highlights lastly massive thank
you to all who have joined us at our
patreon becoming super sexy rejects over
there you can catch the full length
ratch and watch along where you snc up
with your own copy of the impossible
also John and I cover several shows
exclusively with highlights and watch
alongs included thank you again to all
of join is one of the absolute best ways
to support the channel plus you get some
extra goodies on top of that all righty
guys let's see what this movie is all
about I was trying to think of like an
impossible possible thing whatever let's
just watch
it
the deadliest tsunami on record in the
Southeast coast of
Asia admittedly selfishly not as
familiar with the
story damn that is
unnerving whoa is a plane we were
hearing that's a really fascinating
ating opening capturing the like horror
and Beauty Allin
one oh Naomi Watts is in
this all I've ever heard about is young
Tom Holland and EV McGregor yes did you
set the alarm before we left yeah it was
the last thing I did what would the
alarm be I was the last one to leave and
I'm sure I didn't set it no darling I
was the last one out and I did you sure
y you better go across that aisle and
berat her no no I was the last one cuz I
went back in
I guess that means we'll be coming home
to a large bunch of hippies sleeping in
our bed just like your old College
days we're going to have a good day
everything's going to be great what you
doing it's time to sit down we're about
to land darling well talk to
me which one's Tom Holland just sit down
and stop
worrying Place
mad Lucas okay that's Tom all right you
know you could try being a bit nicer to
your brother he's just scared yes
someone else is new everything
scar oh you're going to wish you were
nicer you little
[__] oh Christmas Eve this is a
Christmas movie perfect timing Greg you
know exactly what you're doing in the
algorithm all resorts are full but this
area is really quiet grateful families
the Orchid Beach Resort is brand new we
just opened a week ago you love it here
everything's going to be great we made a
booking on the third floor the SE view
room but we
feel you might play this
better Smo is doing an excellent job at
getting you thrusted into the Wonder and
joy and then they're going to flip it
all upside down isn't it great dad can
we swim in there yeah we can go swimming
yeah it's going to be so much swimming
you have no
idea all joking aside I can feel this is
going to be a really harrowing
experience man 4 3 2
[Music]
[Applause]
1 to this day I still don't know what
that is can you guys tell me in the
comments I suppose I could just Google
it but it' be more exciting if you told
me in the comments isn't going
up it's going a different way than all
the other it's going a different way
than the others kind of like what this
family's going to do
I don't know who directed this but I
feel some certain Steven Spielberg
inspirational touches maybe a little bit
more edited than a Spielberg film but
there's certainly touches ear marks of
him get
off it's
Christmas oh man it's going to be the
shittiest Christmas ever God damn
man
a it's movies like this that really make
me wonder how they built the chemistry
oh my God young Spider-Man it's movies
like this that made me wonder how they
built the chemistry with actors like how
much improvising they had them do
together or what the rehearsal process
was like or what the director had them
do just to get to know each other as the
chemistry of the family feels very
authentic
are they going to give any backstory to
how they're young boys able to do
backflips must be Jack man this movie
thrives on the atmosphere of the sound
design you can just hear that
fan just close your eyes and think of
something
nice that's that's going to be a trick
that really comes in handy you're
hopeless what I'm going to hide that
thing and forget where I push it I I was
just checking to see about the house
would put a bit on in
Japan that phone is going to be very
much necessary at a situation that's
upcoming they can't fire you that would
be too expensive don't worry well I do
worry because we can't afford to lose
this job can we especially with what's
coming up now or maybe it's going to
feel frivolous in the end maybe it's
time oh you want to go home it's not the
West idea is it they're a Spanish family
they're like Spanish like like a West as
a Spanish
right oh [__] again the way they just
know how to like the sound design is so
specific and there's some amazing
framing
here
oh like all chills everywhere nipple
chills
included oh my God oh my
God wa that looks
real
oh my
god oh that's so
horrifying this family survive
that that is so
unnerving
Jesus
Christ oh how
horrible oh
man it is so tragic that this [__] like
this really
happens oh what
he damn that looks shockingly
real
[Applause]
holy oh God you go after your kid in a
situation like
[Music]
that oh
no ooh this move is really already
getting to
oh it's just a hard hard
[Music]
experience oh this is so
kinetic I want to go gra
my oh
[__]
yo I don't know how they made this movie
for damn this look
real God damn
it now the additor on this is
superb
that's a miracle this Ser oh my God you
got to be kidding
me oh
oh so
shr
a poor
kid no did did that is that what
happened Holy
balls yo this is such I I'm already like
I want to like pause the move and be
like what happened in real
life
I'm
here damn
it here that this is tragic
man
careful don't move o boy I didn't I
think this would be
so suspect that to be a little emotional
oh
you just feel like how harsh in
that desperation for a family to
survive it's just these two right
now I'm
scared I'm scared
[Music]
to ah this some great for boing string
music
who who made this
movie this is this done so well already
I don't know why my mind was like is
this a lowbudget film I don't know
anything about like the behind the
scenes at
all oh oh my God holy crap whoa is this
an R-rated
movie you
come oh she is like oh
no it's okay I can't see you like this
okay sorry is just I can't see you like
this oh wow how do you survive with an
open wound like that do this oh so like
the infection that would take
place whoa
oh that tree there the big one do you
think we can climb
it oh
God I can't believe that damn you a real
badass
mom I feel so naive for not realizing at
all what I was walking into it's just
like a straight up survival horror drama
did you hear
that b there's nothing we can do we have
to to get to safety we have to help that
boy mom if another wave Catches Us down
here we will die uh yeah that is
conflicting mom look at you we need help
you cannot risk it damn young Tom
Holland you a good little kid actor man
what if that boy was Simon or Thomas
you'd want someone to help them wouldn't
you Simon and Thomas are dead whoa hey
little Lucas even if it's the last thing
we
do even if it's the last thing we
do act of
Love look there m i
see wow the sets they built for this I'm
like in an admiration of the The Duality
of wow this all really happened to look
how they put this together for a
[Music]
movie what's your
name I'm
like waiting for some terrible
injury Tree of Life to just go from this
like luxurious Escape getaway to feeling
the most
[Applause]
Primal hey got your drink somewhere the
hotel manager is keeping track of you
kid guys this
movies mom coming down just give me a
sec
I can do it Mom I'm coming down I can do
it
Lucas just try to keep it together keep
your composure together for your son
huh oh God damn it oh you could really
feel it it's like my my whole like leg
is just
tingling
[Music]
jeez
God that Andrew Gordon must be
influencing me because when he was
pushing him up I did have that flash in
my head of like Get Up
Spiderman God even like a little knee
scrape seems so much worse than usual
this is one of those movies that if you
told me the what the actors were injured
on set or whatever got scrapes I
completely believe
it a little Daniel
look at that you know you did the right
thing you did the right thing Mom look
look they're coming for
[Music]
us man this movie win an Oscar for sound
design cuz you can feel every little
tiny thing like that sound right now
just scraping up against
[Music]
I don't like it I'm sorry to get a
headache oh [__] really starting to get
a headache from just watching this I
don't even never even been remotely
close to a situation like these
people oh hell yeah where you go
villagers thank you so
much
she is excellent at showing the uh the
pain and
exhaustion these are really good
people was Daniel Daniel Daniel yeah
where is Daniel yeah what happened to
[Music]
Danel
passing the Wailing of all these
suffering victims
Man Too Much Too
Much wow that took me a second to
register what was on the back of that
truck so Lucas is the main character of
this story thought it might just be a
small supporting role for some
reason
so cold in
here
cold oh we need to get her some medicine
badly I need some antibiotics look in
the
cup I can't read the labels they're all
in tight there's got to be some English
look oh look at the S side I I'm at a
point where I would just take anything
oh
please see that boy I'm always got in
the world did you understand
a are you okay that my husband two
children this poor child and Mom all the
countless other people really a miracle
they're alive what color is it my leg is
it still red yeah it's still red it's
good as long as it doesn't turn black
well hell yeah hell yeah the red legs
need to eat on
eat
it so
bossy what's your name my name's Maria
and this is my son Lucas how much loss
has this woman experienced give us some
Tangerine be careful
whoa turn your head to the side please
we'll choke if you
don't please oh God
okay
okay the hell's happening what the
hell's happening mom momy you all right
what are you
[Music]
doing oh my
goodness what the is happening I don't
know Anatomy science trauma [__] enough
to know what's happening what is going
on here what are they both going through
right now after you guys comment and
tell me what's happening with those
lamps that people do in movies you tell
me what's going on here I don't know
what's happening man you got to go and
do something go and help people you're
good at it what you want me to do
something
anything there's just something about
doing good things in a time where it
seems really hard too it really gets to
me man
B [__] from Sweden
Sweden Morton Joseph I'll try and help
you are you are you Joseph benom or
Morton benom Morton benr excuse me
excuse me uhhuh I'm looking for my My
Son Your Son uh Peter Berry two first
AES
Anie Mar Brown sure what's your name
again Anna Marie the brown
anyone wow he's just getting a whole
list is so
touching he hasn't even able to cross
off one
name she get a
clipboard
[__]
benom no
way oh my God I know your
dad Papa you yeah your papa he's here
I'll bring him here okay yes bring him
you have to stay here because it's a
very long way and you have to rest
okay holy [__] man this is something
else man it is so so
touching
b like just fighting that
hope where are you no these
[Music]
people
more Spiderman than
Spiderman this is like something you do
with the Spider-Man game I I really am
going to be soet she's like dead or
moved or
something she was moved wasn't she oh
[__] she's not dead though right where's
my
mom no no what are you
doing
yo little take it easy boy no my mom was
and she took a file you have to come
with me I will help you give some
answers too I really hope she ain't dead
goes without saying pretty obvious
statement to make right now I really
hope she's not
dead this movie decides to go it's got
this incredible ability to go like
handheld and then to do go handheld and
do slow moving shots that get just force
it it staps your brain to focus with the
film it's going to be okay man you're
going to make it
through
[Music]
worst I just can't wrap my head around
being in a situation like this I can't
do it like ah this trailer dropped I got
to get back
home oh wait a minute is this is even
McGregor these are bigger legs is is
this him or is it somebody
else oh my god daddy
lives
Lucas honestly he looks great compared
to everyone else we've seen
Lucas
Mar that frame rate shutters speed shift
if he's only shouting for them he might
have the other two boys right or he only
cares about
Lucas Mo
everyone here this point I'd be trying
to get a
refund oh my God you got to be kidding
me hey man you all right just until I
here a minute you're sending trucks to
drive us all up to the mountains can you
tell them I'm back yes
dad dad a whole load of helicopters just
flew by why don't you come down here a
minute Thomas man these are good parents
I still haven't found them did you see a
lot of dead people that's a question can
we leave yet I need need to do me a
favor Thomas I've heard that everyone's
going to the mountains you see to our
shelter where it's really safe damn his
eye is jacked up I did not even notice
but I can't go with you I I have to keep
looking for them you see you have to
look after some I've never looked after
someone before when I came up that was
all on my own that was the scariest part
and then I saw the two of you clinging
to the tree and I I didn't feel so
scared anymore because I knew I wasn't
on my own you see what if Mommy and
Lucas are on their own right now imagine
how scared they'll be you have to look
after Simon and I'm going to keep
looking for them
yep I wonder what they change
structurally compared to the true story
and the uh narrative is smart you know
like oh you know if if Maria was just
fine we be here going all right they
just got to reunite but we don't know
what happened to Maria she alive could I
use your phone will be really quick our
battery's almost dead we need the phone
wow fascinating this is when you get
that take care of your own kind of
survival Instinct see you in the morning
okay you're not coming I'm not coming we
might know Thomas I'll take care of you
all right and stay with this group wow
you got to leave your two little boys
behind with a bunch of strangers it's
such a desolate situation will you look
out for my boys for me please come with
us I know it's useless don't say that
wow this side of town
sucks I love you I'll be with you
tomorrow
promise I love
you I would have loved it if you
McGregor got unnecessarily jacked for
the
role oh she going to walk Barefoot
through this
this hey man you okay get in the car
we'll drive you somewhere safer physical
turmoil acting in this is so good it is
such good acting heart-wrenching pain my
little girl Gina she's just too the
noise woke me up and saw the sea coming
in land it took me 5 Seconds to reach
the stairs but the water was already
there on the bed I found a note from my
wife saying that they were at the beach
a yeah my whole family were around the
swimming pool when the water hit I found
my middle son first Thomas and then I
found my little one Simon sent them to
the mountains so that I could keep
looking for my wife and my eldest son
damn that is hard have you called home
yet I can't find a phone I'm saving my
battery just in case my family calls
I'll be very quick I promise a little
hope in his eyes of all I got a phone
Ryan yes hry thank God did you hear from
anyone yet no you're the first to call
is everybody all right M came and swept
everyone away and I found I found Thomas
and have to go lots of people need to
use his phone okay call
it I don't know
what's at always was situation like this
truly is like but this feels surreal to
me I promise you I I won't stop looking
until I find him okay I don't know what
I'm going to do cuz it's night time now
but I I'll look in all the hospitals and
I I will find them I promise you that
I'll call you when I do my nose can I go
with
you just hanging on to that hope hanging
on to someone else's hope there's lot of
love in this
movie dark as it is like looking at
stars don't you I can find most of
constellations some of those stars have
been burnt out for a long long time how
can you tell which ones are dead and
which ones are not no you can't it's
impossible there's the title of the
movie he's describing what's happening
in the movie even these random actors
who show up provide so much depth you
feel like full-fledged character your
name is Lucas Bennett is that right and
your mother's name is Maria Bennett is
that correct huh we'd like you to look
at these things please and see if you
recognize any of them that is a loaded
question is that you promised me you
weren't going anywhere I thought you
were dead
Mom how is she she's had surgery on her
chest okay the
[Music]
sheers this is such a daunting
overwhelming
[Music]
experience
I appreciate the attention detail too
even in these montages this the chaos
and the Clutter of all the extras very
well just orchestrated
film wasn't she on the truck where are
my kids they're taking in my way they
wouldn't let me go with him I'm sorry
where I don't know oh my God what now it
just doesn't end they really sell you on
the the title
here the
[Music]
Daniel little angel
boy and if you didn't choose to save
that little boy he wouldn't be with his
dad right
now if I was little Tom holl L Lucas
here I want I want the credit I would
have gone right up to the dad like you
don't know what I did for your kid color
is my leg please don't be
black it's black isn't
it still R is he lying he dropped that
sheet pretty fast this movie just has
his hope never mind her wound's looking
really bad we are doing the best we can
we are taking your mom to surgery right
away why does this woman play it am I am
I just misreading it I I feel like
there's a something kind of antagonistic
about her or something I feel like she
should be kind of comforting we have
checked all hospitals but this one 5
minutes please just only 5 minutes 5
minutes how could you check this
Hospital in 5
minutes anything left in the C
the can don't worry I'll get you
something guys my head is pounding some
has just this incredible ability to
thrush you to the
mood girl this bikini just walking
around all C you got to be kidding me
you got to be kidding me movie this is
some movie [__] right here this not what
how it's not how it went down in real
life this is some frustrating movie
[__] these sideways tracking CHS these
Paul Thomas Anderson shots you got to be
fre stuff like this frustrates me so
much no way did he find her please she's
turning into a zombie right now please
find
her better not be the movie just messing
with
me I'm going to stab
[Music]
someone
this is so frustrating and like right
there oh [__] oh you would know you're
that feels so real you you would you
could know you could identify your dad
from [__] like that you know someone
that well you can recognize their lower
half unless there's some other detail
I'm missing I just if there is let me
know to me I'm like yeah feel like you
just
[Music]
tell
shout his actual name I would just shout
dad a lot of people probably shout dad
need a pink can you hold
it Simon what are you doing Simon says I
need to
[Music]
pee it's the most miserable part of the
movie
sign pay attention to the
[Music]
signs the tug and pull this movie
does there
[Applause]
new this movie is something I got to
look up what happened to this this
family
[Music]
agressively shouting his St at
him
this is is really really moving I just
find the dad would
[Music]
you Lucas you are the C Beast to all
this
luas Dad Lucas
[Music]
did it we did it it did the we did The
Impossible look who's
here oh my God she's a completely
different color my
[Music]
oh man I I I don't know if I can take it
if she dies I don't know if I can take
it we're all
okay this my mind even going there is
like
man am I that
no
you back yes I was so not prepared for
this
fil God I can rest
now I don't know what that means what
does that
mean oh no no no don't do it you're
going to be
fine that's not why I came here
for you're going to be fine they're
going to take good care of you okay
promise you we're going to be fine I
promise you you're going to be okay
we're taking her to
surgery she better live
alls oh
boy I love
you you going to be okay wow this is
really
something I I got like pic just traveled
from like here to the back of my right
eye there's this BL little girl that
hutter hutter whose nose is always
clogged and now I know what it feels
like to be her what you just can't blow
your nose Lucas thanks for taking care
of Mom we took care of each other oh
boy yeah he
did there's something I didn't tell I
really need her to know or love her I
don't know what was
it
hey I have a family
too she speaks I been safe in my
strength because I want to see that uhuh
one more time totally I get it kind of I
I mean I don't know really but you're in
good
hands close your eyes and think of
something
nice that is like the nerd reoccurring
nurturing element that line please for
the love of God
live that is not something nice to think
about
wow
is a God damn
nightmare
whoa holy
[__] Ser like oh God God God God God God
God
God wow
wow it feels
like true
nightmare true nightmare right now come
on metaphorical [__] rise above the
water for the love of goddess
and wow gorgeous it's like choosing to
have
lived in spite of it all
[Music]
[Applause]
rebirth Mom's okay
Lookers we're going home that was kind
of a way to approach
it you do exactly the entire time he's
walking
over you're doing a walk of I got bad
news for you son I'm all T hole from
zerich insurance that sent me to take
care of your family in a few hours
you'll be at Singapore General Hospital
wow how are you here with
you guess what I saw Daniel
again yeah that's right she didn't going
to hear that you're so happy save that
boy he in somebody's
arms I bet it was his dad I certainly
hope so my God can you imagine some
other
guy I love you so much guys I I am
drained what a beautiful story about
like just the Stars story about the
[Music]
stars that was part me kill her
off wow what a shot to addon is final
shot of the
[Music]
movie that's a
miracle that you can survive
that could barely handle bump on my head
on like a
wall God damn right wow what a film what
a powerful
film oh my God it's the real
[Music]
family those are real names too oh I
want
more whoa that's is my favorite Tom
Holland performance man I got a blow my
nose I got such a headache I got such a
bad headache
but you know what it doesn't give me a
headache these guys thank you to Shopify
for sponsoring which is what we use for
our merch store and is our gamechanging
partner in eCommerce so whether you're
launching a passion project or scaling
to new heights Shopify is the e-commerce
Powerhouse guiding you at every step
from creating your first online store to
opening physical locations Shopify makes
it seemless it's perfect whether you're
selling exclusive merch or unique
Collectibles thanks to their
all-encompassing platform for both
online and in store sales their checkout
system unmatched it's 36% more effective
at converting visitors into buyers than
other platforms and let's not forget
Shopify magic the AI tool that elevates
your business with minimal effort but
seriously reflecting on your journey
using Shopify for www.re nation shop.com
it's been transformative the transition
smooth growth exponential thank you
again reject Nation from simplifying
sales to scaling our offerings Shopify
has been a Cornerstone of our success
and Shopify isn't just for us it Powers
10% % of us e-commerce backing
businesses big and small in over 175
countries there are war-winning support
always there to guide you so ready to
join the revolution sign up for Shopify
at only a dollar a month at shopify.com
rejects all overc case shopify.com
reject start your Shopify success story
now let's grow together with Shopify
team big thanks to expressvpn for
sponsoring this video a real game
changer I've been using for years that's
right years so whenever they want to
work with us it's an instant yes you've
likely heard about Express PM for online
privacy and security but there's more to
it than that however there was a very
real incident recently with Spectrum
Shing on my internet and contacting me
due to a suspecting hacking attempt and
funny enough I realized I hadn't
actually activated my expressvpn on my
new laptop that I got a couple of months
ago so I was paying the consequences
having faced a serious hacking issue on
YouTube a couple years ago that made
expressvpn my go-to for both security
and freedom I mean it and yes what
you've heard is true believe me this
channel knows you can use expressvpn to
watch movies and shows on Netflix that
are not available in your country this
means accessing a vast rate of content
of over a 100 countries like a global
Cinema your fingertips it's super easy
open expressvpn switch locations refresh
the browser and there you have it
whether it's kramas on South Korean
Netflix Hulu BBC I player YouTube or
more expressvpn has you covered and it's
incredibly fast ensuring no buffering or
lack for smooth HD streaming it's
versatile too working on not just
computers but phones media consoles
Smart TVs and more this means you can
enjoy your favorite shows on anywhere
any screen protect and elevate your
internet experience so if you want to
get access to hundreds of new shows use
my link expressvpn.com Rejects and you
can get an extra 3 months of expressvpn
for free that's
expressvpn.com reex so head to
expressvpn.com reex to learn more thank
you again all right guys I just blew my
nose I've pulled up
IMDb and all I have learned in this time
is that ja bota directed this movie I
did not catch that at all in the credits
that's not surprising what I wanted it
there it is Jesus Christ been looking
all over for it I was trying to find the
trivia I wanted to read the trivia and
then I'll talk about this movie if you
guys are listening to this on Apple and
Spotify please rate this video just
watch The
Impossible uh the 2012
movie I heard that oh was about the
tsunami and I was like can't I imagine
there probably going to be a few
emotional moments in here but I I was
not expecting to be as enveloped in the
experience I didn't really know what
part of me was actually wondering if it
was just going to be a bit of a Ted if
I'm being totally honest I was kind of
wondering if it would be a bit of a
tedious drama of okay maybe there's
tsunami attack and then it gets a little
dull afterwards but that film that had
me engaged for many a reason uh that I
will go into but I wanted to look at the
trivia really quick here all right here
we go haven't read any of this yet the
scene where the tsunami hits the resort
can only be filmed once it would have
cost too much money to rebuild the set
what what does that mean how do they
film it then how
do I don't understand many of the extr
were actual survivors of the tsunami
that's really cool I mean not cool that
they're survivors of the tsunami but the
fact that they actually use real
survivors of just again I did not under
I don't know what it's like to be in a
situation like this but a register to me
is feeling
authentic um according to Naomi Watts
the producers of the film heard an
interview on Spanish radio where the
family told their s their story of
surviving the tsunami and decided to
make a film Bas on it that's really
that's really
neat they were Spanish right that's
bit I don't know I don't really I guess
they could be well one thing I liked
about it too that I thought was really
cool because I could see this being one
of those movies that is accused of
whitewashing um is that it's not one of
the trivia facts here maybe it's here
somewhere but I haven't got there yet uh
but one of the things that I thought was
kind of neat about it is that uh they
they put a a good amount of emphasis too
on the it was the the actual people who
Liv there who immediately went to go
help the tourists you know this like a
lot of people died and we didn't really
focus on the people who lived there and
so much of their homes and many of those
lives were probably taken as well well
and they put so much Focus here on they
went to go help the tourists the people
visiting I think that was something kind
of beautiful actually man the
performances are so good I don't know
what that has to do with the
whitewashing but it
it I don't know I didn't really think
about the that there might be a
whitewashing thing thrown out here I bet
there was though unless Naomi watchs
Spanish and I don't know that it took a
year to put together the 10-minute
sequence a recreation of the moment the
wave Came Crashing Down the luxury hotel
what
who whoa so they really did that [__]
did they
really that's [__] wild the crew film
partially on location at the actual
Resort since rebuilt where the bone
family was holiday when the tsunami hit
for the tsunami destruction scenes a
scale model of the resort was
used they really wanted to capture they
wanted to be true to this this the
filmmakers had a sense of Integrity here
the real family of the main characters
are based on are fact Spanish but live
in Japan at the time of the tsunami ah
makes a lot of sense for the underwater
scenes Naomi Watts was strapped in a
rotating chair while filming Watts
couldn't hold her breath any longer and
she gave the stop sign instead of
stopping the chair started spinning the
other way around whoa later revealed
that it was a technical error and Watts
stated that she felt very scared and
hated the chair for that reason why
wouldn't
you wow that's Saturday
top all it's feature film
debut that's impressive the real color
of the kids ball was yellow not red this
film's a
liar Maria Bel said it was the biggest
lie in the film yeah if that's the
biggest lie in the film I can imagine
that a lot of this was probably
surprisingly
true Naomi Watts was
nominated uh as rightfully so man was
she
great wait Best Actress Oscar n
performance was the only one in the
category not in the best pitcher nominee
the year oh this film was not nominated
for best if it did not get on in for
sounded on I'd be shocked the opening
scene is a point of view uh well we'll
look at that later uh I'm just trying to
see like the shorter ones this is one of
The Blacklist 2010 Blacklist a list of
the most UN most liked unmade scripts of
the year I always love hearing a story
like that when a script is uh like the
is great but it's never going to get
made and then it eventually gets made oh
that's really
great okay all
right this movies PG-13 I really thought
it was radar I guess it's the handling
of the nudity and the violence that
hopes with it
all uh yeah all right let's talk about
the actual movie I'm semi like
multitasking at the same time right now
cuz my mind is just fixated on [__] uh I
was obviously very moved by it I one
thing that I thought was really I frame
one thing that I thought was
really one thing that I thought was
really interesting about the the script
the first thing about the the scripting
of it all was the the dialogue choices
uh
were I felt like this is
how how would I put it how would I put
it um there's like a the movie has so
much emotional impact and just the right
amount of
sentimentality And yet when they had
these dialogue scenes I would I would
feel like these this is still like what
they would talk about in the moment you
know they wouldn't do a bunch of this
backstory stuff it it was one of those
films where it was so focused on the
immediacy of the
situation and you're kind of being
plucked into the lives of what these
characters are experiencing Ing and what
I I loved all that that whole speech
about the like the the stars and that
they're dead but you could find a bright
light it's like and talking about the
things that are impossible and you know
I I love me a good Bleak dark hering
movie and and this is that but it's also
really contrasted with this family's
resilience to keep enduring and not lose
hope in the face of
hopelessness on on the Name of Love and
and it was that kind of [__] that just
kept breaking me for from beginning to
end because this is such a heroic Tale
But it's about these just regular people
it's a it's it's an extraordinary story
about Ordinary
People ordinary extraordinary people are
ordinary people who do things
extraordinarily well is that the quote I
don't even know that applies to the
situation right now uh but but that's
what was great is it's fun it's fun I
made it like a little crack about this
is more Spider-Man than Spider-Man
because to me this is capturing more of
why we really would love a Peter Parker
because they're doing all the literally
the things that most people would
probably not want to do and making these
choices like saving the little Daniel
boy uh in the face of times where you
were a lot of times in these survival
stories at least the fictional I was
ones you're kind of just looking out for
yourself but this is about aiding each
other and not losing faith and and and
again the the the word of endurance is
the thing that just keeps standing in
mind and and I love how there there was
such a there there's a bit of that
Hollywood in the beginning you know like
Hey we're gonna have a great trip today
you know we're ain't nothing you guys
say Walk Hard ain't nothing bad G to
happen today do we and just setting up
the fact that something terrible is
going to happen but you needed that you
you needed that J the position you you
needed that Switcheroo to kind of plop
you into what it must have been like to
be a tourist vacationing at this
wonderful Immaculate Resort and then
have one of the most devastating things
ever happened to you and because a lot
of people died in this event and then uh
and if you were lucky to survive it's
like what injuries did you sustain
afterwards the trauma that you had to
endure I I so like as much as there's a
bit of like a hollywoodism in the way it
was rid you know I I still thought it
was necessary to get there and by the
time you get to the tsunami and but the
acting was just so consistently great
that it was so believable from beginning
to end and by the time you get to the
tsunami incident like even the way
that's captured in that perspective
where it just hits you suddenly it's not
this big giant buildup like a roll and
emeric movie you're not watching The Day
After Tomorrow where it's like thunder
in the sky or whatever it's just a
couple of things with the blender and oh
a couple little noises and then hits you
that must to put you into the again it's
I love a movie that focuses on POV and
the movie did such a great job on
knowing how to intercut between not
intercut but cut around depending and
and gate with certain characters on
certain uh point of views for an
extended period of time like there was
times I was going oh this is Naomi
Watts's movie oh this is Tom Holland's
movie oh this is Eva McGregor's movie
you know the way they would cut around
to the characters and let you stay in
their perspective I thought uh the
direction of this combined of course
with the incredible
acting man what would the homework like
that's the kind of questions I always
try to find more of the trivia on that's
usually not IMDb like I would love to
know the trivia on that like Naomi Watts
did she sit down with the real Maria and
how many time how long she talk with her
for how much of the conversation she
have to really get in her mindset into
hey let's talk about this moment and
what were you going through and how
therapeutic might have been for Maria to
have been able to talk through that with
her was it therapeutic was it difficult
to um resurrect these conversations and
resurrect these memories and what it
must have been like for Maria to see
that as me wats is portraying it those
kind of sequences you know um those it
got my mind pondering and but at the
same time you know this film has has
such great visual
storytelling because you're relying so
much on an actor's performance and Body
Language expression it's not heavily
ring there's it's not really like
Exposition heavy or they take the time
to reflect on a memory and just talk
about the past like there's something
kind of inspiring to me I could see two
versions where some might not like so
much about the dialogue in certain key
scenes uh but to me I thought the
dialogue was really apt for this kind of
for for what they want to portray here
you know
they at the end of the day this is
about flopping the audience into the
experience of this real
Stark uh
impactful nature
disaster uh with emphasizing the
emotional dramatic weight throughout but
everyone's so good in it my mind's
spinning my headache has not g away at
all if if you only have listen to this
apple spottify I felted a pretty big
migraine and I'm just trying to stay
focused here uh the the
the I guess if I were to rank perform
man this really this is Tom Holland's
debut role and and uh while I do would
ultimately go to me it's like a tossup
between Naomi Watts and Tom Holland is
who's the who's the lead in this movie
like who do you guys consider the lead
in this film cuz I could see it being
Naomi Watts uh but in a lot of ways to
me it was Lucas Lucas to me felt like
this the central character and I and I
thought that was such an interesting
narrative Choice some stuff you could
kind like at the stuff at the hospital I
wonder how real that was with oh my God
they're right there just look over your
shoulder if you just pay attention you
could see them towards the end but if
[__] works on you when when it goes
down that path it works man you know
you're just getting frustrated and then
you're aware it's a movie but damn I'm
just so caught in the moment that I'm
like I don't care some stuff you got to
you got to have some of that dramatic
ump for a situation that I'm sure was
way more dramatic in real life uh but I
thought overall this movie had very
strong Direction uh it was engaging from
beginning to end uh the the ability to
focus on the human aspect instead of the
disaster actually helped Elevate the the
everything about the disaster wasn't
about just going through like the
psychological experience I I thought the
the balance of it was was so
Grand where you could the after effects
of the disaster are are the enemy of the
sto of the story and and it's like the
like the the antagonist of the story is
like the it's so interesting when you
think about it because the you know of
course it's not one of those movies
where there's a clearcut antagonist
you know or you're dealing with there's
another tsunami coming and we got to we
got to go after the antagonist of the
story is all the obstacles they got to
overcome and and also uh overcoming
hopelessness over and and enduring your
faith against that like that is those
are the antagonist qualities you're
dealing with here and to me the disaster
elements that maybe perhaps make great
trailer
moments I I think
were sorry guys my head is so pounding
uh
I think the disaster elements um just
resonated throughout and I never lost
sight of the horror of that because when
you think about the disaster elements of
the spectacle of it the only way that
really stays effective is a you need
your investment in your characters and
you you want to see what what what this
really does do as a turmoil and the way
they would still show once in a while
like oh they're traveling on the road
and you're seeing like these dead bodies
uh or you're seeing like people you know
um in agony shouting stuff out or the
physical deterioration or the symptoms
like the prolonged effects I felt the
disaster elements were kind of non-stop
or even when you know uh Naomi wats in
the Village People are like dragging her
after they rescued her and you could
just hear the scraping against her legs
like those the the spectacle of the
disaster stuff still permeated
throughout the film I felt like it was
still very much alive because you can
only do the tsunami one time and the
sequence of surviving in the flood one
time and I I thought that that that
spectacle that they probably pit you on
still was there in just different ways
and and I found that really impressive
and it man it just plays on your
emotions because this
movie there could be like tragedy poring
in and and this movie to me was not that
it it had it was a bit structurally
predictable at a certain point when you
would go from you know tragedy and hope
but overall because like a lot of times
hopeful thing happened that means in
like I don't know 30 seconds we're going
to get something really tragic or
something to be really worried about you
know so we kind of do that like there's
certain writing books I I think Robert M
I don't it doesn't exactly obey this but
there's like the I forget the name of
that Robert mck book is uh but you know
some people say that every scene if it
starts off positive has to end negative
or every scene that start negative has
to positive you know some type of simple
way of understanding an arc of a scene
so you can kind of see some of that
predictability uh with within the
structure of like when they saw Daniel
um at the hospital it's like he's gonna
go back something Terrible's goingon to
be with the mom or after he finds
Swedish boy he's going to go back
there's going to be something terrible
because that's the tragedy hope tragedy
hope tragedy hope but overall um I
wasn't always hyper aware of it and even
when I was it worked that's the thing
it's the emotion of like at the end of
the day no matter what logical you know
technical aspects even for a viewer like
myself that I can be aware of I would I
I would still just be so in the moment
regardless that it was the emotion that
would be overtaking and to me that is
what Cinema is that that is what movies
are and and I I think this film just
excelled at that so much
uh I thought it was beautiful I thought
it was it really it was a beautiful film
um and it brought me to tears nonstop
and the uh just the the focus on
Humanity
compassion in the face of this
disaster with not a real emphasis on
negative behaviors I'm so used to
survival stories and I mean normally
survival stories can be often
apocalyptic and you're looking at like
the worst of the wor
worst I mean we just saw the movie like
Leave the World Behind on Netflix which
is a rely like sci-fi kind of film and
and um and that has that quality of like
look out for your own in the face of the
danger like the the worst of humanity
comes out and it's it's kind of
refreshing to see a a survival horror
film that feels apocalyptic and and it's
about um human beings coming together
you know cuz uh I saw some I don't
remember where I heard this on uh I
think it they were saying it was Charles
Darwin who who said it that the start of
humanity like what's what's allowed
human means to progress is I'm probably
getting this wrong but the way I have
the way I have um internalized it for
all my life has been
something I'm so focused trying to get
the quote wrong but here's how I
interpreted it or or here's how I
remembered it at least is is that is
love and cooperation I believe the the
the the EMP just is want cooperation and
I I might have applied the word love
underneath that because I feel like
every emotion comes down to love or fear
and this movie to me shines a light on
that the love and cooperation side in
spite of all this you know and I'm not
someone who is often I I feel like I'm
so much in my own bubble a lot of the
time that I don't take enough time to
like learn about other things around the
world enough I try to I really do um
it's often very very late at night right
before go to bed where I'm like you know
what I'm feeling inspired oh my God I'm
in a really dark place now because I've
decided to learn about some stuff and
that I'm just on my phone researching
for like hours asking my wife questions
because she knows about all this stuff
and I don't um and yeah yeah yeah this
is great this is great and also like the
emphasis on
um I don't know uh trauma and Recovery
is is another way to put it and
um it just kind of reframes the way you
how would influence the severity of and
impact of natural disasters like
tsunamis you know it's something that
out here you know I'll hear about it's
the way I hear about a lot of terrible
things that happen but after a while
when you just hear about it on the news
it just becomes a thing you hear about
right something that you it becomes
information you become numb hearing
about which is terrible it's but it's
the reality of of how a lot of us
ultimately respond and this brings you
to oh my God yeah it's such like this so
terrible so
terrible and I'll be stressing out about
how I gota I can't get my upload up on
YouTube you know like oh my God I got to
work on the edit for this video I gotta
get notes on this video I gotta get the
thumbnail right I gotta do all
this like my mind was thinking to myself
like I have a headache right now but man
what was the headache like for them I
should just endure this headache as I
was watching this
movie oh man uh yeah I thought this was
a great film and thank you guys for
being with me and being patient and and
you know it's it's interesting when
you're filming one of these and you're
by yourself because it just feels like
you're I have such an I I I do have I
was diagnosed one of the benefits of
doing reactions that I think is like
really awesome is it it's it's allowed
me to express everything that goes on
internally with me more than like what
is my wife I'm I'm pretty respectful
when with other people if if there's
like not not doing this my wife and I
it's kind of like exactly when there's a
camera pointed at me the way we just
talk about things everything is just on
our mind throughout the whole time and
and uh I was diagnosed uh way back when
ADHD PTSD and type two bipolar right and
it's some random thought that hit me
is having the ADHD mind has really been
great for me to be here because I have
so many thoughts that go off when I'm
watching a movie and it just allows me
to express all that and I feel like in
real this is real life for me I I feel
like a lot of the time I I have to in I
have to like hold back because I know
people are can be like shut up Greg I'm
trying to watch the movie and maybe some
people feel that already when watching
one of our videos but what I love about
this experience is I'm like oh now it's
a perfect excuse to get all these
thoughts out while I'm watching
something for the first time it's a
great time all righty guys uh thank you
so much again much love happy holidays
and uh man it's a Christmas movie who
would have
thought all right John pick a name oh
Brian Perry Brian Perry you know what
you're getting for Christmas this year
you are going to
get a book
about the best positions in the bedroom
yeah for when you're you're by
yourself yes the karma the K selfa yeah
and I'm telling you self en enjoyment I
don't know what words get us flagged
here self self fun
of oh there's a there is a technical
term for this damn self the technical
term get flag look what position you put
us in yeah jeez it's not one of the
positions you're going to enjoy though
you're going to have a great oh yeah
you're going to people are going to be
like why is Brian never showing up for
work oh dude he's why Brian not at
Christmas dinner with us hean never has
to leave the house again open in the
present went to his bedroom and now it's
2025 someone did such a good job yeah
that they don't need to do anything for
Brian ever again you're going to master
the art of self-love yeah with this book
that I have personally written and drawn
my
myself yeah and checked it for you
specifically custom made for you Brian
Perry
handbound on the finest paper on the
finest artisanal craft paper that we
could find at oh yeah man insert sticky
joke ha hey anyway Brian much love to
you Merry Christmas hope you have a
great New Year and uh say hi to the
mirror for me buddy yes see you
soon